there's nothing quite like the
anticipation of a multi mega million
dollar movie making its theatrical debut
and nothing like the agony of watching
it go down in flames
not every big-budget Hollywood
blockbuster makes Bank at the box-office
and sometimes do use guess wrong about
what will and will not perform here are
some of the films that have been
surprising disappointments 47 Ronin with
a large budget a reliable kung-fu
fighter is its star and a plot that
included both samurais and Dragons 47
Ronin was supposed to be the kind of
action-packed blockbuster that makes for
a reliable end of your hit unfortunately
the behemoth of a movie turned out to be
too unwieldy for its first-time director
Carl rich plagued by problems requiring
extensive reshoots it was delayed by
more than a year and despite the biggest
best Christmas push the studio could
muster 47 Ronin only made 38 million
dollars in the u.s. far short of its 175
million dollar budget
JOHN CARTER the insanely high
expectations for this tragic bomb of a
movie may just be one of hollywood's
great mysteries because in hindsight
it's belly flop at the box office should
have been a foregone conclusion Taylor
Kitsch was a popular cast member in
Friday Night Lights prior to being cast
as John Carter's main character but he
was hardly a bankable star for a 250
million dollar space opera but that's
exactly what Disney did and the problems
were compounded by one of the most
grossly mishandled marketing campaigns
in the history of cinema ultimately Jon
Carter was an earth-shattering
disappointment that left the studio with
a whopping 177 million dollar loss in
the u.s. before turning a small profit
internationally still it wasn't enough
to keep it's two hopeful franchise
afloat battleship the you suck my
battleship jokes write themselves when
it comes to this 300 million dollar
albatross battleship had all the makings
of a big summer blockbuster with a cast
of well muscled dudes during the ship
and high hopes of leveraging the same
eighties kid nostalgia that made the
Transformers franchise that's a giant
moneymaker right a month but at the box
office
battleship suffered from stiff
competition from the Avengers bad press
and a bad reputation for leading man
Taylor Kitsch well you might remember
from its mentioned 55 seconds ago
although the movie made back its
production budget once it hit
international waters it still left
Universal taking an eighty three million
dollar bath
depends the Lone Ranger before Johnny
Depp's personal reputation started to
sour his professional presence was
supposed to be a reliable predictor of a
film success so with him sharing the
lead Disney Pegg The Lone Ranger movie
is a big moneymaker at the outset
pumping north of 215 million dollars
into the production but even once it
became clear that the Lone Ranger wasn't
going to break any box-office records
the ultimate losses were wildly
unexpected the film ultimately didn't
even make back half its budget in the
u.s. due to dismal audience interest
okay don't come see if I care
the cast and crew blamed unfair reviews
for quashing ticket sales but others
pointed to whitewashing and stereotyping
of its native american character Tonto
as troublesome perhaps they want to make
it look like Comanche violated easy
Ender's Game based on a classic science
fiction novel by Orson Scott Card set in
outer space and with a cast that
included up-and-comer asa butterfield
and everyone's favorite star warrior
Harrison Ford Ender's Game was a movie
with seriously high hopes but despite
the box office promise of a big-budget
movie about teen soldiers battling
hostile aliens while the fate of the
earth hangs in the balance
Ender's Game was plagued by issues
including the effects of a boycott from
groups who are angered by the author's
stance and same-sex marriage between the
bad press stemming from that and mixed
reviews from critics it ended up barely
recouping its hundred fifteen million
dollar budget
Fantastic Four after a slightly cheesy
but successful pair of fantastic four
films rocked the box office in the early
2000s a fresh round of films featuring
Marvel's first family seemed like just
the thing for an up-and-coming director
Josh Trank who'd done great things with
the found footage thriller Chronicle was
tapped to helm the pick but the
promising young cast in tow producers
were counting on the foursome to become
the next big thing in superhero
ensembles alongside the x-men and the
Avengers what they were counting on
unfortunately was for traying to clash
with the studio and behaved so
erratically and said that Fox felt
compelled to reshoot huge portions of
the movie after the fact the finished
product was ghastly by all accounts
which makes it unsurprising that the
film took in only twenty six point two
million dollars on its opening weekend
and 168 million dollars worldwide
against an estimated 200 million dollar
production and marketing budget Jupiter
ascending after The Matrix everyone was
on pins and needles to find out what
wild
world wachowski had cooked up with
Jupiter ascending the film had all the
ingredients of success including two of
the coolest kids in Hollywood Mila Kunis
and Channing Tatum in the lead this
story of a cleaning lady who learned
she's the heir apparent to an
intergalactic Empire had the full force
and faith of big money behind it to the
tune of a 176 million dollar production
budget which house Keys reportedly
overspent on the film test audiences
were unimpressed and the critical
reception was extremely chilly all
adding up to a worldwide take of 184
million dollars that didn't compensate
for the massive budget and marketing
cost of the picture
Mars Needs Moms if you've never heard of
Mars Needs Moms
lucky you the name is a pun of Mars
Needs Women a 60 sci-fi b-movie that was
just as bad as this one on paper it had
all the makings of a hitch including
fresh visuals thanks to advanced motion
capture technology and a family bonding
plotline with a cool alien twist but
nobody could have anticipated what an
unmitigated disaster the release would
be not counting the cost of marketing
Mars Needs Moms cost 150 million dollars
to make and even with international
ticket sales its total revenue was just
shy of thirty-nine million dollars
making this film a planet-sized flop for
Disney thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]